all right saw
Hey so uh where are you from originally
where'd you grow up I grew up in uh
Houston Texas
tell me about how you grew up so uh both
my parents been married since you know
30 years ago um had a very good
childhood actually you know my parents
provided everything they could
financially emotionally and so on I mean
I have a twin brother we'd always go to
summer camp and on crazy family
vacations and so on and um I also had a
lot of support from my grandparents who
lived across the street from my family
and they would you know hang out with me
and my brother pick us up from school
that sort of thing so it was really an
ideal childhood sounds great yeah what
kind of kid were you in high school
pardon me what kind of kid were you in
high school man I was a kid that was
always getting in trouble that was that
was the first thing that came to mind
for me I mean I was a smart kid I went
to a private high school in Houston St
John's and you know it's prestigious
school and everything but I was always
getting sent outside of the classroom
because I had poor impulse control so I
would blurt out random videos I saw on
the internet and do things like that so
I was getting in trouble a fair amount
but I'd still say I was a good kid
despite that I think that I always had
my friends best interests and I think I
grew up a lot from middle school where I
was actually more disrespectful to peers
and so on I felt like I was just more
impulsive and a little still immature in
high school but I think I was a lot
nicer of a guy is it was your twin
brother similarly
see that's that's an interesting point
my twin brother and I were both in the
same friend group really in middle
school and um identical twin or just no
fraternal for tournaments twin brothers
yeah yeah fraternal but um we had the
same friend group really in middle
school and so we were pretty similar in
that we were always making jokes and and
so on and uh actually at the end of
eighth grade my brother did a speech for
student council uh where he made fun of
a lot of things in the school and just
totally went off script and he had a
talking to with our principal and that
actually really shaped him up in high
school and he was a lot more by the book
really committed to his studies I ended
up going you know ivy league and
everything but as a fraternal twin he's
definitely his own person yeah
absolutely and I was actually a little
bit difficult for me to cope with at
times because I would have people
sometimes come up to me and say oh you
know how does it feel that Gabe is the
Smart twin and so on and I think damn
you know one of my chopped liver and
apparently yes because he was going on
and doing all these great things and I
kind of was left behind in my immaturity
it seemed like it's hard having siblings
because it always ends up being a
comparison right I mean if I was an only
child it would just be okay this guy's
you know a jokester whatever but oh this
guy's a jokester and his brother is
gonna win the Nobel Prize someday or
something I mean that's a little bit
more daunting I would say what did you
do for work when you gotta when you were
done did you go to college I I went to
uh undergrad at Trinity in San Antonio
now I'm actually in graduate school at
Southern Methodist in Dallas I'm doing a
degree in mental health counseling but I
worked part-time but how old are you I'm
25.
25 years old yeah
and what kind of things did you want to
do with your
career see so that you know that this
has really influenced my whole
life I guess is is my career aspirations
I mean from an early age I thought I was
going to be a sports broadcaster I was
very obsessed with the Houston Astros
even when they were losing over 100
games I was their number one supporter I
know I remember sharing a story once to
the media about how the Astros lost a
random regular season game and I beat
the Wall in my room with my belt because
I was so angry and I chipped the wall so
Sports was in my blood I thought I'm
going to be a broadcaster my parents
actually sent me to a sports
broadcasting camp in Boston One Summer
and then later sent me to like some
sports communication summer program so
that was always in my in my blood and I
had my own like catchphrase you know I I
remember I tell everyone guys don't
steal this but when I'm an announcer I'm
going to say at the end of the game
paper or plastic because this ball game
is in the bag and I thought man I'm the
smartest guy out there so that was what
I wanted and then uh really transformed
from from that once I really got into
sports betting and then I figured being
a sports announcer would kind of be
antithetical to getting away from the
world of gambling and gambling kind of
took hold yeah sports sports betting so
I figure um should maybe delve into that
unless you yeah that's why you're here
yeah absolutely that is why I'm sitting
here
um so yeah you just a little backstory
of how I got there
yeah yeah how to start okay so I mean
first first off is it in your family do
anyone else yeah actually that's
um you know there is a hereditary
component I think that people often
Overlook my dad's father
um was a huge Gambler back in Algeria
where he's from and I heard he was
banned from casinos in France and
Algeria he would pawn my Grandma's
jewelry to pay off his debts and so on
so he had that problem so it is
somewhere in the family
um my history with gambling actually
doesn't start with the sports betting I
was doing in college so from a very very
early age and I don't even know what
prompted it other than my own interest
but I loved scratch off tickets so from
a young age I remember whenever I'd go
to the store with my mom I would say I
can have a dollar two dollars you know
go play the scratch-offs and the Machine
and every now and again should say sure
you know whatever and um
we get scratch offs in my birthday cards
and holiday cards and uh I remember like
I would be so interested in it and then
my brother would have the same scratch
off cards and he would just say what the
hell you know I'm gonna scratch him and
I would stand over his shoulder watching
saying oh that's only one number away
from a million dollars you know oh you
almost got it and so I was very
intrigued by that from an early age
um I also have a few other Recollections
of just the seeds being planted with the
whole gambling interest
um I was always going well not always
okay I was often going with my parents
and my brother to uh the Sam Houston
Race Track in Houston my dad's a huge
horse racing fan and he's not a gambler
actually but big horse racing guy and so
we'd go and bet a little money on the
horses and I just have very positive
memories still in my mind about the lady
Margie at the ticket window and she
would always say how are the boys doing
you know how's school going and I
remember thinking man I want to be like
these guys who I didn't know were just
like throwing away their family chain
smoking you know betting on the races
overseas that's what I wanted to be like
when I was I don't know like an eight or
nine year old kid because I thought I
loved the horse track the smell you know
there's smoke in the air it's all very
very cool so I had that and then
I also um on a cruise ship so you know
we went on a cruise one year for summer
vacation and they had Bingo on the
cruise and so my brother and I were
affectionately known as the Bingo Boys
by the people on the cruise ship and so
I remember once my mom and my brother I
think won one of the Bingo cards and it
was a few hundred dollars almost 600 I
think and I remember my parents pocketed
the money and I thought God you know
that's so annoying I I would love to
have that money I would love to be able
to do this on my own so I had these core
memories I also you know we had high
school casino night at St John's and I
convinced a kid to put nine on number
nine on roulette and I did the same
thing and we ended up winning and I
remember that telling me Oh I'm good at
this I'm going to brag to all my friends
and I was able to buy Astros tickets
with my Casino winnings from that night
and so I have all these really good
memories not to mention I was always in
a fantasy baseball
and um that was how my friends and I
really stayed close from middle school
through high school so I already played
fantasy baseball and uh now here's the
part that actually is directly related
to my sports betting so played Fantasy
Baseball for years and then my sophomore
year at Trinity in undergrad this was
2017. I had an acquaintance of mine from
this uh Camp I mentioned earlier this
Sports communication camp and um he
messaged me saying oh you know you're
always helping me with my fantasy
lineups and
now I'm on a sports book now I have a
bookie why don't you hop in with me you
know we'll bet Sports make some money
it'll be fun
and um what's crazy is I remember just
not really wanting to because I I you
know I didn't want to lose the money I
had in college I didn't have a job I
just had money saved up and I thought
well it seems a little risky but what
the heck you know put in 10 bucks and um
that's crazy that that's how that
started because for me it was as casual
as someone saying hey we're gonna go
bowling tonight you want to hop in yeah
sure I have nothing better to do it
wasn't you know if someone asked you hey
you want to go do a line of cocaine I
would probably say oh no you know that's
scary but with gambling oh you want to
go bet on baseball sure whatever so it
seemed very innocent yeah is
and it it grew from there right
absolutely so
um you know I I try not to just bore
people with all the War Stories you know
this was the box score this was the
pitcher no one really gives a but I
think I mean it is important to mention
the first couple of games because that
is really what got something going in my
mind so I I do try to do it justice by
saying that first game that I bet
September 20th 2017 uh the Royals
against the Blue Jays meaningless
regular season game both teams were
under 500 so they'd won fewer games than
they had lost really bad teams and I
remember thinking well the Blue Jays
have this pitcher who's really awful
Royals are going to win put down 10
bucks and it was like I had been cursed
or something because I didn't know it at
the time that this was going to fuel
this compulsion or this interest but the
Royals were up nine to nothing in just
the second inning so my bet had pretty
much
one after only like 15 to 20 minutes and
so I really convinced myself I'm the man
I know everything about sports everyone
else is a loser you know I'm I'm this
winner because I remember also when I
made that bet I was doing something on
campus where I was wearing a suit and
like you know nice pants and nice shoes
and so all of that combined like the
winning the suit doing it all from my
phone like oh man I'm so I'm so cool man
I'm just doing all these making these
plays from from my phone I don't even
have to lift a finger make any effort in
my life I can just do this so all of
that was already going and so
I enjoyed that first win clearly and um
placed a bet on football that weekend
and it was the Bears against the
Steelers and I just said oh you know
intuition just gut feeling that the
Bears are going to beat the Steelers it
shouldn't have happened I mean they were
huge underdogs and then the Bears ended
up winning so oh man you know this is
this is my game and so I from there
started betting more frequently and
eventually within the first few weeks I
want to say I got access to an account
online so
what happened initially was I was
texting this kid that my friend knew and
he would place the BET once the BET
concluded he would venmo me the money
that I'd won so it was just you know a
text exchange basically on an honor
System but then I wanted to bet more
frequently so then I was actually given
access through this guy to an online
account where
you know I was set up with a web page
with an account login and password and
gives you a certain amount of credit you
can use to gamble for that week and by
the end of the week it's like okay
square up you know you venmo him or he
venmos you whatever the amount is won or
lost so it really I got access to a
whole other dimension of this gambling
Universe because before I just thought
well I'll pick a football game but now
it's like drawn line and now some tennis
match in Bulgaria is the next thing on
the Slate and I have access to wagering
on it so it's a whole world of
possibilities
the impulse control the lack of impulse
control that you had as a kid is that is
that a key component and absolutely I
mean that's that's the thing and here's
the thing I mean I try not to go on a
soapbox about the whole
messaging that that's being put forth in
the industry today in the sports betting
industry but a lot of this stuff of oh
you know just be responsible just have a
cool off period do better money
management for some impulsive 19 year
old kid who's a sports junkie and has
this
compulsive Drive none of that stuff came
into play I mean I I was initially not
even considering the potential to get
sucked into it I just figured and maybe
this is just my issue but my my thought
process was I'm good at this I enjoy it
and I'm winning money so I'm a for
only betting ten dollars you know why
would I not bet fifty dollars because
I'd want 50 instead of 10 I mean that's
clear so that's yeah definitely played
into it I didn't have this rational
approach to it and that may not be the
case for everyone I mean I'm not here to
tell you that every single person who
places a sports bet is going to be
in the throes of Despair I just think
that it's important to recognize that it
does happen and it happens to people
that would be considered book smart like
myself I mean private school education
through sixth grade and so on I mean I'm
not an idiot but I'm behaving like one
and I think that a lot of people don't
recognize that
there is personal responsibility
involved but then at a certain point
it's just this compulsive drive this
impulse you you were mentioning
and those memories of
hitting the right number on a roulette
wheel yeah
winning you know the the Bears
game and just making a bunch of money
those memories are etched into your
brain oh I'm sure forever and I I don't
try to relive The Glory Days and you
know try to remember what you know that
that felt like so I can bask in the high
of it or anything like that but I think
it is important to recognize like at
least for me
um that that stuff is always there and
so while I'm not gambling now I haven't
gambled for about three years and just
about 10 months but it's something I
have to treat every day this problem and
I don't think that's discussed well
enough out in society it's like okay you
have a gambling problem stop gambling
the end but
I think for me the stopping part was
easier than staying stopped because
there's so much pressure and I know it's
it's set in different recovery
fellowships like oh a baby will take his
hand off a hot stove or something like
when the pressure becomes enough anyone
will stop
but how do you stay stopped five months
later when your finances look better
people start to trust you and
um there's a tennis match on no one's
home like how do I prevent myself from
going back into it at that point and
that's where you know there's a lot of
hard work and so on where I think it's
not being recognized now and we're just
starting to see how this problem is
going to look across the uh the country
and there's all kinds of brain chemistry
things going on sure the endorphins the
adrenaline that gets right jacked up
when you when you win or even lose right
right yeah no I've heard that a near win
you know a close loss or something you
know elicits the same sort of response
in the brain in that the response of a
gambling addict's brain is similar to
that of a cocaine addict I think is how
it's been described and um yeah I know
there's just a lot going on and um what
I think is also important to share is
that such a dangerous addiction mission
to have because it's all mental so you
know with alcohol of course I mean I'm
oversimplifying it by saying if you put
down the alcohol you know you're not
going to be drunk I mean of course
there's more to it of the emotional
sobriety and so on but at least there
there is a physical component to it
whereas gambling is it's just mental you
know there's a mental response to the
action of placing a bet so you're
getting high pretty much within your
mind without ingesting anything without
drinking anything and so it's like I
can't escape my mind unless I just die
and I think that's why there is such a
high suicide rate associated with this
problem because people cannot take the
mental torment that they have to deal
with hour after hour even when they're
not gambling you know thinking about the
next bet thinking about the next lie
they have to tell not being able to
sleep because you know day Ho Lee just
hit a grand slam over in Korea and you
have to make sure you documented that I
mean it's crazy so um
yeah yeah it's just it's a mental a
mental problem really and most of the
compulsive gamblers that I've
interviewed or met
have all been very intelligent sure not
on drugs you know alcohol sometimes
comes into the picture but right but for
the most part they're stand-up citizens
that are just
compulsively gambling right no I think
that's a great point of losing their
their marriages their jobs everything
well I think yeah I think what's really
uh a sort of fascinating case study into
this problem is you take someone take me
and I'm you know not going to speak for
everyone I'm speaking for me you look at
myself grew up to a really privileged
household parents were together parents
were nurturing always at my baseball
games everything sent me to the best
private school in Houston yeah I said
that Kincaid and Episcopal St John's
number one but best private school in
Houston you know always had manners
always polite yes I had impulsive issues
and so on but I'm not the type of person
I think of when I think this guy is an
addict because growing up it's like we
never even had conversations much at all
at home about don't do this drug or that
drug because like first of all I don't
even think my parents knew what any of
that stuff was the very specific Niche
drugs because they were never put in
that situation and so it's like not even
an afterthought it's like why would you
even think that you need to tell your
sons not to
become addicts or whatever because it's
just naturally not going to happen and
then all of a sudden this gambling thing
comes up when people think they're so
intelligent because there are factors
that seem like they can be controlled by
intelligence such as gauging how the
weather will impact a score of a game or
the wind conditions and so on and I
think that's a unique part of gambling
that does apply to intelligence where
you know I've never ingested like hard
drugs or anything but I could think oh
I'm going to take this drug and I'm
going to get high end of story with
gambling it's like well I need to plan
how I'm going to win or how I'm going to
manage my bankroll and so on so there's
a lot of mental calculation that goes
into it
um and if we have time I definitely want
to share the Little Secret that the
industry has to try to convince you that
you have some sort of edge so yeah I
cannot share that yes okay so one of my
buddies actually who's a recovering
compulsive Gambler was telling me that
long ago he had some bogus webpage like
wizards of Las Vegas or so some gimmicky
website and pretty much how it works and
this is referring to people that claim
that they're tipsters and they'll give
you the best picks on the games if you
subscribe to their web page so anyway
it's a little back story so pretty much
what they do what these guys do is
say you have a base of 600 customers on
your site okay
so for the first pick that I'm giving
all 600 of my customers say it's a game
between the
the Celtics and the 76ers so I split my
participants down the middle I assigned
300 of them I give them the Sixers as
their pick 300 of them I give the
Celtics so automatically one group is
one for one the other group is O for one
and I keep splitting the pool so you see
if you keep doing it enough times you
are guaranteed to have some guy who's
six for six based on the picks that you
gave him and it's just math it's not
that they know anything about the game
or anything and they don't care that
they have whatever guy that's o for six
because they just need the testimony
from the guy who is six for six and that
person will have the statements to
verify it they'll show you all the pics
you gave them they'll show you that they
made those bets and that you were six
for six and that's what gets people
buying into these referral services so
so many different hustles yeah it's
crazy because you'll go on one of those
websites and it'll say well the reason
why I'm six for six is because Mike
cousin is the trainer for this team and
he gave me this it's all Bs you know
it's just oh we just split the pool
enough times to where someone had to
turn up six for six on their picks and
it's crazy because
really when you look at a lot of these
TV shows on major networks now they have
all these shows dedicated to
prop bets and over under two and a half
strikeouts for this pitcher and uh it's
very dangerous in my mind because first
of all you're giving people this
illusion that they can be good gamblers
and that they can win at the system and
so on and you're you know fueling that
dream world but at the same time you're
also endorsing specific methods of
gambling that that are very harmful and
have the potential to become addictive
because now you're not telling people
who's gonna win you're telling someone
who to bet on in this inning in this
player and it speeds it up to where that
can progress really quickly and I think
this whole digital landscape of gambling
is a whole lot more addictive than when
you were looking at someone's sketchy
Uncle going to Atlantic City for a
weekend I mean this is 24 7. you can
lose your house while you're naked
length and bad I mean it's really absurd
but it's true and that's why I think
this this topic really needs to be
addressed in a truth full you know
truthful honest whatever I'm losing my
mind but needs to be addressed it seems
like a lot of it is
you know it's not intelligence as we
just spoke about right it's right it's
almost like your your brain chemistry
your your lack of impulse control is
what drives you and even though you know
it's a racket you know it's set up to
work against you you're still gonna do
it that's even though you're not drunk
and you're intelligent and you
understand that it's a racket you still
believe that you can win well that's the
scary thing I think is that really once
a person has become addicted they're now
performing this activity against their
own will and it really is like being in
a prison of One's Own making and you
know what's helped me is and I don't
name any program or Fellowship whatever
because of you know the anonymity and so
on but I've been in a program that has
taught me to not fight against it
because this whole idea of being strong
and I'm just going to use my willpower I
mean it sounds good in in like an action
movie but in reality it's it's really
actually detrimental because fighting
the compulsion mean it's just a battle
that can't be won so doing a lot of
journaling doing a lot of phone calls
going to Fellowship meetings of people
that are like-minded struggle with the
same issue really opens up my mind at
least to Alternatives that are healthier
and don't involve this gambling and of
course for me there was there was a bit
of a withdrawal process I mean mentally
having that urge and like you know I
need to call someone I need to do some
writing because
like I mentioned it is a thinking
problem and so writing stuff out has
been really helpful and freeing in
seeing what's true what's not true and
really giving me a healthier perspective
what was your lowest point
so uh financially or emotionally or just
I mean both okay okay so little context
I mean I say my date in my program I
don't mean to laugh at it no no no no
I guess yeah yeah I know I think I have
this Gene too yeah yeah I got you I
don't I don't gamble but right doing a
project like this is oh it is yeah
but um now I mean I I say my abstinence
clean date is July 18th of 2019 and um
I you know I wouldn't even say that was
my lowest point really because uh in
August of that same year so that next
month I I had been clean from
gambling for about a month and
um I was like a dry drunk as as is
sometimes referred to so I wasn't in
action but I wasn't getting better
emotionally spiritually I just wasn't
betting I mean I I didn't have a
resource I was messaging all these
people trying to get them to give me
more credit and put me on a website and
I wasn't finding it so anyway I wasn't
gambling but I remember uh the girl I
was dating at the time uh broke up with
me then in August because I was just a
really awful
person toward her and I just remember
when she dumped me I just remember it it
was like everything kind of came to this
boiling point where I recognized that my
whole life was pretty much toast and
I've reached out to a mentor of mine and
I said hey would you please tell this
girl if I don't gamble for the next six
months tell her I've changed tell her to
get back with me and like everything
will be okay and um this guy told me
you have no shot of changing or being
abstent from gambling or anything unless
you start really working on yourself
you're being very stubborn and things
like that and so he was basically
showing me how serious the situation was
that this was a life or death situation
and um I don't know that that's
something that people are really
comfortable talking about because it is
a sensitive subject but it needs to be
talked about because that's the issue
that I'm dealing with is is an issue of
life or death and I think that was my
lowest point was realizing okay first of
all I was like 20 grand in the hole with
money I didn't have because I was doing
all these Bets with different bookies
that were extending credit and so on at
what age uh like 19 20 21. it's a lot of
money for it it's money I didn't have I
mean for a kid you know yeah like I had
some money that my parents had given me
to spend at school but it wasn't like I
was waiting on my next Bugatti or
anything I mean I was getting by because
I didn't really have expenses but if
you're gambling 20 grand if you're in
the whole 20 grand at 20 years old it's
a lot it's like each year of my life I
was adding another thousand to that
which is a lot yeah it's gonna double
every year which is yeah I mean that's
that's a whole other issue
um but I think to wrap up that question
of my lowest point it was just
recognizing that
and it wasn't even the money wasn't the
biggest deal to me then and I think that
that's overlooked as well is that yes I
cared about the money yes I wanted that
money back and I regretted losing it and
so on but it was the whole
development of my life to that point was
like dude you know you your parents
spent all this money for you to go to
these Great Schools you're given every
opportunity and instead you just decided
you're just going to gamble your life
away and you don't have a girlfriend
don't have meaningful relationships it
couldn't be honest to anyone such a liar
and um
yeah it was a culmination of all of
those things really is it's something
about your self-worth
that also isn't in play here with with
the whole gambling where are you just
don't I don't know how to sit on a word
this but any better than this but just
saying like thinking that you don't
believe don't believe you deserve a
better life than
than to suffer and and I yeah I think
that is a big part of it too I know like
the more you respect and love yourself
the less sure right destroying your life
well I think I mean a lot of that and
I'm not going to go in a whole therapy
session here but I think that I did have
issues with self-esteem and so on and a
little brief anecdote I mean I remember
the after party of prom in high school
all my buddies were drinking alcohol and
I think somewhere like smoking weed or
smoking whatever and I just remember
that really hitting me and I was
thinking I'm being left behind you know
I don't drink or anything and I I've had
this pit in my stomach like I'm not cool
anymore no one No One's Gonna think I'm
cool I'm not invited any parties I would
always get really scared and nervous
that my other friends were going to
parties and so on and I remember just
that night I try to drink a
non-alcoholic beer and ended up like
spilling it on myself and crying about
the whole thing and it's just like this
whole situation made me feel really
pathetic that I was about to go off to
college and I was a loser I didn't have
anything that was cool and then you know
what's up peer pressure yeah and I mean
it extended into
being in a joining a fraternity in
school and I remember the first night of
orientation they they said hey who
you're still a virgin and I I mean
I'm not gonna lie so I I don't think
anyone else raised their hand and so
from that point on their whole motto was
GSL gets all laid and I remember
thinking well I mean what was I doing in
high school I was just playing video
games and like playing basketball I
wasn't going out on wild like sex
parties or anything peer pressure's a
yeah I know it's crazy so they
even put it on like we had a brick that
was a part of our you know frat Ensemble
that had designs and so on and say GSL
and I remember because I brought all my
frat stuff home so I remember for the
longest time I would come home when I'd
see my family in Houston and I'd see
that stupid brick in the garage and just
say GSL my parents probably oh you know
that's just some they probably never
thought about it and it's just laying
there so every time my dad's driving me
home from dinner it's like oh you need
to get laid son I mean it's just right
there is just a reminder and so there
was that that feeling too and I think
gambling for me really
gave me this high that I didn't have
from those and so I I'm you know I'm not
getting late I'm not having sex at this
point I'm also not drinking I'm not
doing this and uh
at least I have gambling you know too
you're not tight with all your buds
right doing the same drugs they're doing
yeah exactly and I thought well if I'm
gambling I actually am more powerful
than everyone else because no one else
was really doing it and um I was and I
thought well with all this money that
I'm making from it and at least early on
I was and I thought that was what would
give me self-esteem give me power and so
on
but what's helped you
you know you're doing you're doing good
for a while right now yeah it's been
years now that you've been staying away
from that what's what's helped you the
most you think I think what's helped the
most is is the fellowship I have with
the people that are also gamblers I
think without that I mean it's such an
isolating problem and I think that it
wouldn't seem that way we have the
secret for each right losing Gambler
right so many yeah yeah there's so many
lies and I think it doesn't seem that
way maybe because with sports it's a
team game people watch sports together
but sports betting at least at the level
I was doing and it's very isolating
completely in my own mind you never talk
about the losses yeah that's true
actually I think the only I think I
would sometimes talk about them but only
in a weird sort of bragging way like
dude I lost lost five G's whatever like
as if it was some sort of flex like I
can just lose that it's no big deal so
it was a very backward way of describing
the losses when they happen but
um now I'm trying to remember oh yeah
yeah the connection the connection has
been what's really kept me on the right
path because it's like now if I have
people I'm talking to every day that are
also dealing with this issue and
actually relying on me for some support
and so on it's like I want to be
accountable to those people
um but I think something that really has
been helpful to me and uh I don't I
don't know that it's really talked about
either is that
I have all the stuff to fall back on
like there was a lot of incentive for me
to get clean because of family
opportunity you know going to a school
that would provide really good
networking opportunities having stuff to
fall back on so I think there is a lot
of motivation for someone like myself to
want to get clean at a young age but
that doesn't account for
people that are older or people that
have no family no money they're living
out here like on Skid Row or something
in their gambling attic what is going to
motivate them to change because they
probably know that they're destroying
themselves but at the very least it's
numbing them from The Bleak nature of
reality at least for me when I stopped
it's like okay my parents are taking me
back in you know my friends are
supportive
um everything is just about normal I'm
still paying back my debts and I can't
gamble safely again but
so be it and uh I wish I had a great
little answer for how people that are in
poverty and so on can stop gambling I
mean I guess I would just advertise that
my life has gotten a lot better and I
believe that their lives would also get
better if they stopped but it's very
hard to convince someone I think really
all right soft thank you so much for
sharing your story yeah absolutely
thanks for having me fascinating thank
you I love this topic cool thanks yeah
post